The Carter Center in Atlanta Georgia
was founded by former President Jimmy
Carter and his wife Roslyn nestled in a Park
area the center's work stretches around the
world striving to ensure human rights and ease
suffering it's a democracy democracy program
focuses on helping fledgling democracies
conduct free and fair elections mostly by
sending observers to monitor voting they're
doing that again this year but the election
they're monitoring may surprise you
Barry Peterson reports from Atlanta
Guyana South America 2020 election observers from
The Carter Center found problems but a recount
five months later led to a peaceful transition
of power Tunisia North Africa 2019 another of
the more than 110 elections worldwide where
Carter Center observers watched over contest
our southeast Asia 2015 their first free
elections their first step towards democracy
where they found many could not vote because
of violence or discrimination these are all
the elections we've observed since 1989. David
Carroll is director of the Democracy program at
the Carter Center in Atlanta and he personally
observed elections this year the Carter Center
has a new troubled election it is focusing
on hours what does that mean that means
we've realized that the the situation in the
in the United States the threats to democracy
and to our institutions here are greater than
in many countries around the world both sides
are selling mistrust in election results as did
Democrat Stacey Abrams when she denied losing
the 2018 Georgia governor's race we won and
Donald Trump when he lost in 2020. there is
this year even before the first votes some
candidates already say they won't accept
election results unless they win that's the
nightmare scenario if people don't agree to
a peaceful transfer of power I mean that that
is the fundamental element of of a democracy I
understand what you're saying but I sense
really and truly there's a bit of fear in
what you're thinking about oh a great amount of
concern and fear of what could happen in this
country if we are not able to get ourselves
back on on the right track fear of what
fear of you know this country no longer being
a place that is genuinely Democratic hardcore
take no prisoner partisans get the publicity but
surprisingly it's not what most Americans want a
new poll showed two-thirds of respondents want
candidates who will compromise to create change
the Carter Center will observe elections in
three states this year Georgia Arizona and
Michigan watching voting or election preparations
experience it got in 2020 when it observed the
recount in Georgia that confirmed a Biden Victory
and in 2020 Gabriel Sterling now Georgia's interim
deputy secretary of state issued a blunt warning
as emotions on both sides boiled over and some
election officials faced death threats it has to
stop someone's gonna get hurt someone's going to
get shot someone's going to get killed what
do you feel overall just bring the focus back
out of Georgia and across America are you
worried about the direction this is going
generally speaking I remain hopeful in these
situations and what we have to remember is
not all these people are evil people all these
people who are thinking the election was owned
they believe in their heart of hearts their
actions are protecting American democracy and
like 2020 this year there are more threats to
officials and volunteer workers it is taking a
toll when you're a poll worker or thinking about
being a poll worker and you face these kinds of
threats let's be honest how does that affect your
mental health it really can have quite a serious
impact on people's mental health especially
in the the longer term Avery Davis Roberts is
associate director of The Carter democracy
program and a veteran of several overseas
elections how does that play out they tell
you stories about being afraid to be at home
by themselves because of the threats they've
received some people just start crying men
women Republicans Democrats these are threats
that have really impacted election officials
from all walks of life the midterm election is
a dry run for the big prize the presidential
election of 2024. will there be a free and
fair 2024 or will we have lost our way by then
asked me after 2022. the message is as clear as
it is ominous the many battles over democracy
and voting may end up destroying democracy itself
for CBS Saturday morning Barry Peterson Atlanta
interesting when he says will we have
a free and fair 2024 and he says ask
me after 2022. also early in the piece
talking about this idea that the threats
here are greater than in other places in the
world in trying to have a democratic election
I was still watching it because you know
I felt the wash of history in the moment
of watching that piece go by because
we've seen this before in our country
um many times but we've gotten over the hump
the question is will we this time around